[Music]
hi our hon here I'm an enterprise
customer engineer at Google cloud and
hide from me Priyanka I'm a customer
engineer and I help Google cloud
customers understand their big data on
an episode earlier we looked at managing
containerized applications with
kubernetes engine and you had the chance
to deploy a containerized app in quick
labs you can check out the link to that
episode here on this episode we're
taking it to another level through a
hands-on lab you're going to learn how
to build a slag pot using barkat and
then run it on kubernetes engine you'll
also interact with the bots in a live
slack Channel okay so quick recap on
kubernetes engine containers addressed
the problem of how to easily and
consistently deploy apps in different
environments by allowing them to be
broken into smaller independent pieces
these can then be deployed and managed
dynamically container is a ssin also
allows the separation of apps from
infrastructure leveraging Google's
infrastructure kubernetes engine
provides the perfect managed environment
for deploying managing and scaling your
containerized applications by simply
describing the compute memory and
storage resources your apps containers
require kubernetes
engine automatically provisions and
manages the underlying cloud resources
in this lab creating a cluster on
kubernetes engine will ensure that it
adds a new node to your cluster if your
pods don't have enough capacity to run
conversely if a node in your cluster is
underutilized kubernetes engine can
delete the node you'll also use
kubernetes engine to create a deployment
but users enable workspaces to interact
with external services or your custom
code and have many of the same qualities
as their human counterparts but users
have profile photos and names they can
be direct messaged or mentioned they can
post messages and upload files and they
can even be invited to you and kicked
out of a public and private conversation
the biggest difference between bots and
regular users is that instead of
interacting with the workspace through
mobile or desktop apps BOTS a control
programmatically through api's within a
slack channel BOTS can do nearly
anything you programmed them to do all
right time for quick laps in this
hands-on lab you are going to create a
bot that posts a simple message by
completing the lab you're going to learn
how to create a custom bot integration
in slack build in node.js image and
docker upload a docker image to a
private google container registry and
run a slack bot on kubernetes engine you
can check out the links to start the
quick labs here keep in mind that it's
going to take you about an hour to
complete the lab requires access to a
slack team where you're authorized to
create custom integrations to set up the
lab you cloned the code repository and
install node.js dependencies we then
create a new slack app add a new bot
user to the app and get the bot user an
auth access token
we added the node.js file with the OAuth
access token we run the bot in slack we
can see that our bot user is now online
we send our bot a message and get a
response we hope you enjoyed this
episode if you developed other cool
slack BOTS we'd love to hear about them
if you haven't signed up for the $300
free trial credit on GCP check out this
link it's a great way to apply what
you've learnt all of our additional
training resources are linked below
thanks again for watching and see you
soon
want to know more about deployment
manager check out our full episode where
we dive into a lab and highlight the
service